No matter who you ask
or what year you're
talking about,
the idea of flying cars
always seems to come up
as cementing
when the future has arrived.
So, what future
were we promised,
how far have we gotten,
and how much further up
do we have to go?
And I'm Marques Brownlee
and I review dope new tech.
But on this show,
I'm rewinding the clock
to look at the tech
of the past
that we thought
would be our future.
This is "Retro Tech:
Flying Cars."
Hey, what's up? MKBHD here.
I know I'm unboxing
something today
that has something
to do with flying cars,
that it's this, uh,
iconic piece of tech
that apparently
was going to usher us
into this new era
of personal transportation.
We'll see about that.
This is definitely
the biggest box
we've had on this show.
There is no indication though
anywhere on this box what it is.
It's like a riddle.
What would be a piece of tech
that would promise
to revolutionize
personal transport,
but also not fit
in a smaller box than this?
I'm guessing it's not
a flying car.
There is a giant wheel.
Oh, is this the Segway?
Oh, it's a Segway.
I know what a Segway is. Okay.
I cannot wait
to try to ride this.
It's really hea--
oh, well, it has to be heavy
because it's got
to counterbalance.
There it is,
the original Segway.
Is it a flying car? No.
Is it even a hovercraft? No.
Well, let's get into it.
This is the
"Welcome to the evolution
of personal mobility" pamphlet.
Lots of warnings.
"Don't roll this over bumps.
Don't ride this
over curbs and steps
and obstacles
and steep slopes
and slippery surfaces
and loose materials."
Whew.
All right.
Can I get a helmet?
Okay, I'm going
to be the expert.
I'm going to put all the swag
that came with it on.
This is a Segway armband.
The expert would probably
have this on, right?
It's too bad
I'm too swole for this.
I'll probably have
to put it on my wrist.
That is nerdy. Wow.
I hate to break it
to you, Segway,
but this is the nerdiest part
of this whole thing.
There you go.
Let's fire it up.
Oh!
Okay.
I'm a little dizzy.
I'll be right back.
Wow.
That was fun.
Is this a flying car? No.
But this is my segue
into the next segment.
I'm gonna have you
check underneath your chair.
( laughs )
Oh, yeah, it's my buddy.!
Oh, guys. It's the '80s?
It's the '80s in a car?
A DeLorean, a DMC-12,
with Mr. Fusion on the back.
This is the flying car
that most people think of
when they think of
a flying car.
Marques: All right,
I guess let's walk back
to, like, the concept
of flying cars in general.
Why was this such
an obsession for us?
Negin:
It's kind of not surprising
that Americans
would be obsessed
with flying cars
because we're just
a car culture.
- ( engine revs )
- ( tires squeal )
Tim:
The key to the automotive
interest in the United States
has been always
that notion of freedom.
Announcer:
Well, the automobile
has brought with it
a new way of life.
And that freedom is just key
to the American experience.
Cars are everything
in America.
Even though we don't have
flying cars today,
it's not because
we didn't try.
Announcer:
Just an ordinary plane,
but, wait.
Negin:
There's been multiple versions
of attempts of cars
that were supposed to fly,
and they crashed.
Tim: Well, one of
the earliest flying cars
that actually looked like
it had a road to production,
it was called the Aerocar,
way back in the 1940s.
The Aerocar,
it had the wings in the back
that could turn it
into a functioning airplane.
And this 60-mile-an-hour
car takes off.
Announcer:
Let's put traffic woes
behind us
and fly
that wild blue yonder.
Joseph:
Is it a car that can fly,
or is it just a plane
that can be broken down?
( imitates explosion )
Cooler heads prevailed,
and the Aerocar
didn't move forward.
Marques:
Okay, so, there were
actually some attempts
at flying cars for real.
But how did science fiction
impact how we thought
about flying cars?
Science fiction has really
been obsessed with flying cars--
movies like "Blade Runner"
and "Star Wars,"
and of course
"Back to the Future."
The first time I ever
saw a flying car was
in "The Jetsons."
Joseph: The Jetsons
have moving sidewalks
very similar to the ones
that we see in airports,
television screens
where they can video chat
like we do with FaceTime,
and they have flying cars.
So you say to yourself,
"Well, why not flying cars?
Why can't I have a flying car
in my garage?"
Caseen:
It's the ultimate fantasy
for everyone.
But obviously there are
all sorts of challenges
to making that happen
in real life.
Marques:
So, science fiction can help us
imagine the future,
but just envisioning
a piece of technology
isn't enough
to bring it into being.
No matter
how compelling the idea
of a flying car may seem,
the technology
and the physics
just doesn't seem
to want to play along.
So, today I'm meeting up
with fellow car tech enthusiast
Gali Russell
from HyperChange
to find out just how close--
er, how far we are
from this future
of flying cars.
Marques:
All right, so I guess
the basic challenge
for a car like this today
to get it to fly
is to get all the air
underneath it.
Yeah, it's a first principles
physics problem
of literally moving
all of this air super quickly
with enough force
to get some sort of lift-off.
Marques:
Getting all that air
underneath the car,
that sounds like
a lot of energy.
To lift it off the ground,
we would need
1.6 megawatts of power.
And that just gets you
into the air,
and then you have
to stay there.
Yeah.
Even if we theoretically
solve that problem,
how are we transferring
the air below the car?
So, there's two schools
of thought
of how we can actually
get enough force at once
to lift this thing.
You could have some sort
of propeller system,
- basically like a huge drone.
- Right.
And then you have
Elon and Tesla working on
literally repurposing
rocket tech
with all these kind of
mini cold gas thrusters
to get it to lift off.
Okay, so, a system like this,
if you were to build it
into this car,
how would it work?
Where would you put it?
So, this is where
the system would go.
Okay, so the back seats
are just gone?
Yeah, we're pushing
the laws of physics.
You'd need to use
all the space.
Marques:
So, that's the cold
compressed air,
the pumps, the thruster,
everything's going back here.
- Gali: Yeah.
- That's a dramatic
amount of space
- to remove from
the inside of a car.
- Yeah.
Marques: So, basically,
to get this nearly 5,000-pound
car off the ground,
you would need around
1.6 megawatts of power
for the car to hover
with no forward movement.
And this model's
100-kilowatt hour battery
would be able to sustain
that hovering
for about 3 to 4 minutes,
as opposed to
the nearly 400 miles
you'd be able to travel
if you stayed on the ground.
And the calculations
only account for the weight
of the driver,
so if you want to bring
your friends along,
your time in the air
would be even shorter.
All right, so, we're making
our way into the future.
The original idea
for flying cars though
was just, like,
get from point A to point B.
Maybe there's better
versions of that future
that aren't flying.
The Tesla in some way
embodies that
because what makes it
so advanced
is not that it can fly,
but it has software.
You know, it can
kind of drive itself.
I wasn't around in the '60s,
'70s, '80s, '90s when
we were imagining flying cars,
so when I first
was growing up and thinking
about the future of cars,
I didn't think
they should fly.
I thought, "Wow,
they should be more like
the high-tech stuff
we have today."
And now we're actually kind of
seeing that start to happen.
Our desire to innovate
and create
the next revolutionary
technology is never-ending.
And so while we may
still be pretty far away
from a world of flying cars,
there is another type
of cutting-edge flying tech
that we've been dreaming
about for decades.
- Hey!
- I need to borrow your...
Hover Board?
Nothing captured the imagination
more than Hover Boards.
I wanted one.
I know as a kid, that's
something you could feel
you could talk your parents
into buying you.
A DeLorean? Not so much.
I mean, what's better
than a skateboard
than a skateboard that can
lift you off the ground?
And I remember as a kid
believing that these things
might actually be real.
As a joke, Robert Zemeckis,
before the film came out,
gave an interview and said
that Hover Boards were real.
Zemeckis:
They've been around
for years,
it's just that parents' groups
have not let
the toy manufacturers make 'em,
and we got our hands on some.
Tim: Of course,
it was all made up. It was all
part of the marketing buzz.
But they made
so many kids excited
that everybody wanted 'em.
But it never really came
to any sort of reality
until we started to hear
about this revolution
in personal transport.
So, it's the early 2000s
and we start to hear this buzz
about this transportation
product from Dean Kamen,
who was already
a well-respected inventor.
It was codenamed "Ginger."
Tim: Steve Jobs
comes out and says,
"This next thing is gonna be
bigger than the PC."
It is rumored to be
the technological advance
of this century,
an invention that could change
the way people live.
Bigger, perhaps,
than the Internet.
It's finally time
for the big reveal.
Tim: So, we all tune in
to "Good Morning America,"
which was the biggest
morning show of all time.
Dean Kamen's
standing there talking
with Charlie Gibson
and Diane Sawyer.
Negin:
They lift the curtain...
Do we have to do
something here?
...and it is the Segway.
It's the Segway.
- Gibson: Okay.
- Tim: It's basically a scooter.
The best part of that launch
is Diane Sawyer
trying to hide
her disappointment
at finally seeing this thing.
I'm tempted to say,
"That's it?"
Negin:
There was something
about the Segway
that just evaporated
people's dignity.
Joseph: It kind of, I guess,
lacked that cool effect.
'Cause, let's be honest,
once they removed the handlebars
and they became
hoverboards,
people were going crazy
for them.
This is what everybody's
talking about.
It's like a Segway
without the handle.
Announcer:
They are also referred to
as hoverboards.
The 360 hoverboard.
The antithesis of the Segway.
Celebrities are riding them,
like Justin Bieber
and Kendall Jenner
and Martha Stewart,
who is obviously the coolest.
And then the other
weird thing about it
is that it caught fire
all the time.
( screams )
It got so bad that
"Saturday Night Live"
actually had to do a parody.
Announcer: And now they're
literally the hottest,
because they also explode!
Ultimately, they were a failure
because they were a failure,
but they also didn't live up
to the thing that we all wanted,
which was
"Back to the Future II,"
hovering aboveground.
Marques:
Despite tech companies'
best efforts,
hoverboards over the years
haven't had
the best reputation.
So, I'm here
with actor, writer,
and comedian
Michael Ian Black,
and we're gonna test out
a few of these models
to see if any of them
won't kill you.
This is Dope or Nope.
Michael,
thanks for joining me.
What is your experience
with hoverboards over the years?
- Almost none.
- Okay, perfect.
I guess we just get
into the first one.
Here it is
under our desk here.
Uh, this is what--
this is what I'm used to.
- Right.
- I'm from this era.
- So, you have experience
with this.
- I do.
- Do you?
- No. No.
Oh, this is gonna be good.
Marques, I'm 49 years old.
What this looks like to me
is a stress fracture.
- Button. Okay.
- ( beeps, chimes )
So you look
kinda like this.
Yeah, that is not
superior to walking.
But you just look
so much cooler.
This is--
this is already dope.
I know I'm giving this
a dope already.
- This is amazing.
- I mean, you do look cool on it
because you have
a kind of confidence on it
that I don't think
I'm gonna possess.
- ( beeps )
- Oh-- all right.
Oh, jeez. Oh, come on!
- Jesus.
- All right, here.
Oh, my God, I've never
felt older in my life.
- Slowly get your balance.
- Mm-hmm.
I'm not trying to move.
All right.
That's not bad.
There you go.
- There you go.
- Do I look terrified?
You look better than if
you were walking that speed.
- Yeah.
- Oh, my God.
- You were really good at that.
- I love this thing.
- I have to give it a dope.
- Much to my dismay,
I also have to give it a dope
because I want to
be able to do it.
All right, dope.
Next up.
- Oh, jeez.
- Oh, boy.
I've never seen
one of these.
It's called the Airwheel.
To me, it looks
like a Rascal
that you drive around
in the grocery store,
except that--
just so much less safe.
- I'll try it. Yeah.
- Want to give it a shot?
- All right,
so I'm gonna get on.
- You think kickstand out
- and you just go for it?
- Just...
- give me a second.
- All right.
I'm terrified.
Bailing looks
a lot harder on that.
- But you look comfortable.
- Yeah, well, I'm sitting.
Sitting is something that
I feel like I do fairly well.
I know I look like I'm taking
a ( bleep ) right now.
When you're too lazy to walk
and even too lazy to stand,
this is the gift gizmo for you.
- You want to try it?
- Yeah.
You looked much cooler
on the other one.
Marques: Yeah, this is--
this feels kinda ominous.
This is a great solution
to a problem nobody had.
- I'm gonna say
that's a nope.
- Nope.
All right, next up.
Ooh, that's heavy.
- Wow.
- Segway Robotics.
I mean,
I'm sold right here.
"Robot inside.
The future is coming."
Which is pervy. I'm sorry.
That's perverted.
It's got a name. Loomo.
Open the box from the front.
That's the front.
Well, that seems to be
the robot. Out.
Oh, look at the size of this.
Here's the power button.
( whirring )
Does it balance itself
and roll around by itself?
- Seems to.
- I'm gonna get on it
and see what happens.
- All right.
- It's a hoverboard
in some respects,
but I'm not even sure
what it does.
I know my feet go here.
Much easier to get on
than the other thing.
- Oh, jeez.
- Oh, my God.
I mean, it's cool,
but what is its purpose?
I don't know.
Oh, my God,
there's a transform button.
- Michael:
Oh, it transforms?
- You transform it,
the head swivels around,
and it's a robot.
Michael:
Weird. Okay.
Loomo personal companion,
follow me.
Loomo: Here you are.
I will follow you now.
Please watch out
for the people around.
Okay.
Come on. Come on.
Come on.
It's your personal
transportation and it's
your camera on wheels.
- Hey, Loomo, follow me.
- I cannot find you.
- Stand in front of--
there you are.
- I found you.
- Hey, Loomo! Follow me.
- ( dings )
- Follow me, Loomo!
- I cannot find you.
- I'm right here!
There you are.
I found you.
I found you. I found you.
Dang.
That's locked in right now.
- Michael: Loomo, sit.
- Loomo, stop following.
Loomo: I cannot find you.
Please stand in front of me.
- I cannot find you.
- Loomo.
Please stand in--
there you are.
I found you.
I cannot find you.
Please stand in front of--
there you are.
The technology is perfect.
God, it's so cool
and I hate to say it,
but there's just no
good use of it
and I can't imagine
it's cheap.
- So that's a nope.
- I agree with your
entire assessment.
It's nope.
Sorry, Loomo.
I cannot find you.
Marques:
Although we're not
quite there yet,
in theory, riding around
on hoverboards
is a future
that's within our grasp.
So to find out just how close
we may be now
to that reality,
I'm gonna speak to a duo
that's spent the last 10 years
perfecting their
hoverboard technology--
Alexandru Duru
and Philippe Maalouf
from Omni Hoverboards.
So, if you were to explain
this hoverboard to me,
someone who's never seen it,
what is it and how does it work?
Alexandru:
The hoverboard uses propellers.
The propellers apply force
on a larger area.
Philippe:
Using the propellers,
that's the challenge.
And to succeed with it, that in
itself was the innovation.
Marques:
The Omni Hoverboard
has an array of
10 miniature propellers,
which are powered
by a bank of batteries
in the center console
and a handheld throttle
that allows the rider
to control the height,
which can be as high
as 100 meters.
How do you think
your hoverboard is different
from the hoverboards
that people saw
in, like, movies and TV that
they might be inspired by?
Well, one thing about the movie
"Back to the Future Part II,"
it was an extension
of a skateboard.
And a lot of people wanted
to create a hoverboard
that looked visually
like the one in the movie.
But for us
to have a hoverboard
that functions the way
it does in the movie,
we had to not care
about how it looks.
It's all about functionality.
It's not like
you're riding the vehicle.
It's you yourself
that's flying.
You lean in one direction,
you will go forward
in that direction.
It's like a surfboard,
but you're surfing the air.
It's biomechanical.
It's an extension
of your body.
It's a bit like you
acquired a superpower.
I'm sort of picturing,
like, a futuristic field
where there's a bunch of people
all sort of hovering around
and going
through these courses.
It's a fun world to picture.
Yeah, it's fun just to fly.
Like, it's a real trip.
I mean, you know,
some people just want to fly it.
I think that's the best part
of the hoverboard.
The very idea
that you're flying,
it's a classic dream
of mankind.
I think the hoverboard
could be the beginning
of something.
All right, after all that,
I guess, uh,
turns out flying cars,
aka giving everyone
helicopters,
is probably not the best idea.
But I still love the idea
of recreational
individual flight.
Like, I think if you ask
anyone what superpower
they would want to have,
a lot of people would say
they would just want to
be able to fly like a bird.
So maybe let's keep
working on that.
Thanks for watching.
Catch you guys
in the next one. Peace.